welcome back to new rockstars one
division series finale
definitely made a mark uh it may have
confused you it may have made you cry
it may have presented some questions for
what's coming up in the mcu
and we're gonna do our best to give you
some answers uh hey spoiler warning for
the season finale if you are just
joining us now
i'm eric voss i'm here with jessica
clements how you doing jess
i'm feeling mad and this video is
brought to you by
privacy privacy lets you buy things
online using virtual cards
protecting your identity and bank
information on the internet and that's a
treat for my viewers new customers will
get five dollars to spend on their first
purchase when they go to privacy.com
new rockstars to sign up now this is a
bonus episode 9 q a that we are doing
with our listeners on stereo we're
recording this live the morning of the
episode drop
uh download stereo for free at uh stereo
dot com slash new rockstars let's take
our first question jess
in your opinion why do you think vision
did not tell wanda that he
uploaded his memories into white vision
oh yeah
i guess he just didn't have time but
realistically he should have
he was probably so emotionally like i'm
about to lose my wife
and i love her and my kids are asleep
and they're going to die
um yeah that hex wall was rushing it was
coming quick
she he was like just the imagine being
like i have 30 seconds to tell you
exactly how i feel but i don't want to
lose you i feel like he just didn't have
time
but realistically i guess he should have
been like
it's okay i might be gone but there's
another vision running around with my
memories you can
somehow get him to love you yo maybe
he's like
it's kind of like a lover's about to die
who doesn't want their spouse to remarry
it's like oh yeah now you'll forever be
a widow
okay no no but we should talk more about
we should talk about white vision right
and like what he is now in the mcu going
forward because
he has all the memories of vision it was
kind of like a callback to ultron right
of when a vision grabbed ultron's head
and because we know you've all been
watching ultron it's been like
recommended please watch this after
every episode of wonderful
and his his mind uh glowed from blue
to uh orange go gators
and the
[Laughter]
but yeah i think that's what this means
now we are now vision in the mcu for all
intents and purposes
is just gonna be the spectral vision and
he's gonna have a role to play
and i think that's why vision didn't
tell wanda is she didn't
he didn't want i want to interfere with
what this visions journey is going
forward
he understood that this vision now
needed to move forward without being
tied back or held back
by the scarlet witch i think i also
think that this vision
still has questions so he still was like
figuring out himself as a robot
so i do think overall right now he
probably went back to sword to go
figure out like i was a corpse and they
were gonna use me as an asset
or he could have gone back to like stark
industries and been like
this is what i feel like he's because he
can't time he can't like jump like
wanda can right he can't just go through
realities and even if like
sword didn't give him that ability to do
that so he's stuck
on earth yeah he's like where is he
going
yeah so it's like where is he going on
earth and i think it's to find more
about himself
um because but i do because i don't
think
loving wanda is still an emotion and he
just got the memories he didn't get the
feedback
no you're right jess i think that was
the when
wanda said what are you you are the part
of the mind stone that exists in me
so uh spelling out that link white
vision doesn't have that link
he uses his own thing that's just kind
of the corporeal form of visions corpse
and uh when she put her hand over him in
sword headquarters she says i can't feel
you
so i think that was why vision just kind
of let white vision go on his own
journey they were just talking about the
the ship of theseus this logical
philosophical argument
about what is something made of
essentially
uh they kind of spelled it out in the
episode but the ship it's the easiest
thing it's like
it was an argument presented by plato a
lot of these ancient greek philosophers
uh in which like once the the pieces of
something get swapped out
is it still what it once was and i think
the the argument underneath that is
what makes up the the identity the soul
uh
where is it is it nested in your head is
it in your brain is it in your heart is
it all throughout your body
like if your body gets stripped limb
from limb as vision has been
where does his where is his soul nested
where is it rooted
uh and the argument at the end of the
day is that
both of them are kind of still the the
essence of it
and or what vision actually said was
memory memory makes
yeah we're getting like a gamora without
fast forward but we're getting like a
gamora story where it's like
like gamora lost like amore god
oh i don't know big question we talk
about this a little bit in our big
question that's going to drop on tuesday
which you guys are going to have such a
ball
it's so bananas it's it's me and tommy
beck told so you can only imagine how
crazy it is i can't wait to see this i
love you guys so much i can't wait to
see
i was like as soon as it was just me and
tommy i was like oh my god we're going
to go so crazy
but yeah it i i do think that vision um
i don't know he's just he's just
wandering his vision
and he doesn't have that wondering
there's so sad if we get
wanda meeting up with vision and being
like i'm still in love with you and he's
like i don't have the same feelings
and it's like
thank you um yeah he goes um
i'm just here with my friends because
i'm just with my friends i'm trying to
have a girls night
well that's why i think a spectral
vision's destiny might be to be a mentor
figure to the young avengers
he might disappear for a while uh he
could be a component of multiverse of
madness
uh i don't think paul bettany's been
confirmed to return a multiverse of
madness he might be there as a cameo
uh he might come out at the very la and
the very end and then we're gonna be
like oh shoot it's white vision again he
came back
yeah but i think we're we're getting to
a version of the vision that we saw at
the end of age of ultron
just like pure philosophy uh yeah
i loved his debate with ultron at the
end of age of ultron he's like
something isn't uh great just because it
lasts you know
uh and this is that whole ship of
theseus reminded me of that
uh and i i can't i can't wait to see
just like the philosopher-in-chief of
the mcub
vision because paul bettany does it so
well um let's take another question
what the [ __ ] is dr strange excuse for
not pulling up bro
sorcerers are bringing my ass more like
uh taco bell crunch trap supreme
i wish i could take the audio and save
it forever that was so
freaking funny more like the crunchwrap
super he is the taco bell crunchwrap
supreme dude he has to talk about extra
cream
i i mean crunchwrap supreme is actually
useful and tasty
uh dr strange is nowhere to be found
just eating his ice cream with wonk he
is i said it earlier i think he just
straight up is
busy doing something else and this is so
minuscule to him of like
and that's what we're gonna see i think
it's gonna be the same time
so it's gonna be him dealing with
something that's much bigger like
it's like his problem can swallow the
world well
wanda's vision wanda is just swallowing
the small town of new jersey
so to him right and doctor strange hates
new jersey
yeah he's allergic to him he hates new
jersey he said i saw jersey shore and
i'm never going to that place
it's literally right across the river i
can see it from my penthouse and i'm
never going to smell it and i'm not
going there
no i but i think to answer your question
the best i can
is yeah like he's gonna be entering the
chat soon
in multiverse of madness but right now i
guess they didn't want to pay benedict
cumberbatch to be in this they just gave
some heavy knots but it's not just
doctor strange dude it's all of the
avengers why did they just leave
wanda out to dry right now like hulk is
around
i don't think they were alive he's like
we don't want to overshadow vision and
wanda that's what this is
if you bring in these other characters
it overshadows their story it's it's uh
it's a story thing
but you're right it doesn't make sense
and this is a massive threat why weren't
more people helping
it it was but it's still again it only
which is not
a good excuse but it only encompassed a
small town of west view
it was not like a million people like
new york when they're getting
destroyed it was literally like 30
people
yeah well and hayward made it sound like
he covered it up like he was able to
keep it a
secret but doctor strange as a
sorcerer's supreme like agatha could
sense the hex and she just floated over
there she's like what's this magic
it's like she smelled some barbecue
cooking next door and then she's like
i'm hungry she brings her own tupperware
and loads it up like dr strange should
have done that
he's a wizard he's not far he should
have sensed it i think
long should have showed up for sure just
to see what the hell was happening
but then they wouldn't have won against
agatha
no i think yeah well i don't know if
agatha versus strange i mean
strange and wong together i think could
have handled together yes together yes
but
one by themselves i don't especially if
they went into that basement which i'm
sure she'd lure them into
um and they can't i mean strange strange
totally could yeah maybe if she lured
him in the basement you're right
um but strange is sorcerer's supreme
that guy can like jump through
multiverses and [ __ ]
he's like he can and he's smart uh he's
he's
in super control with his powers there's
book knowledge and then there's street
knowledge though and i feel like agatha
has street knowledge
well that's been a long a lot longer
she's been a lot around hundreds of
years
so yeah exactly so it's like she first
hand experiences it while he just reads
about it
not saying that reading about it won't
make you smart it's that like she's like
yeah i've been
actually practicing with it i lived with
it for hundreds of years
you're literally a surgeon that lost
like just shaky hands like i'm not gonna
what you lost your shaking hands you
lost your shaky hands
like i don't know what to tell you which
is what i also said about wanda earlier
i was like wanda would beat dr strange
because she's been
birthed with this power and has it
forever whereas he still again
is a man that just got it and was
reading about it it's kind of hard to be
like
i read all about it but it's like yeah
but did you live with it
did you practice all the time yeah it's
a good point
it's a very good point um let's take
another question from stereo
ralph is the missing person and do you
think that's his real name or it'll be
revealed that he's someone
else also i know the show and i love
this show
oh thank you so much i don't think so i
appreciate that
yeah i think uh guys uh
the way that i kind of have to put
mephisto to bed for now uh we can maybe
look at him for the future
the show could not have been more clear
about how uninterested they are
with like ralph and evan peters going
forward yeah
i think his name is ralph bona the fact
that they showed us two pieces
of information like that being his name
i i don't think he's a missing person
because they would have spelled that out
more uh and like it's weird for a young
actor to be someone who's in federal
witness protection
right like he's like why if you're an
actor when you're in federal witness
protection they tell you to avoid all
media they tell you not to go to
sporting events because you might be on
the jumbotron
like you're not going to be an actor
printing out headshots with your face on
it if you're in federal witness
protection
so that's my issue with that and i think
he was just
uh agatha kind of invaded his home made
her
made him her husband 100 and uh
unfortunately there's nothing more to it
than that and i think this whitney
was a missing witness of jimmy wu
unfortunately there's nothing more to it
i think honestly it was just by the
writers trying to get the fbi into it
no i think that's all it was is the fbi
is the bureau that handles uh
missing persons and i think the idea was
he had some other person in this town
who vanished along with it and their
family and their friends were like
i never heard of that guy and that was
just an extension of the hex
and that's what drew him into it but i
think this is
i think it's not great writing honestly
i i overall the writing on the show has
been amazing
but i don't think there's more to it
than that i think they just needed a
quick justification to get the fbi
involved
and i think it was poorly thought out a
poorly thought out way of doing it
uh because otherwise it'd be an easy
thing to address in this episode and
they didn't
and when else are they gonna address it
did we figure out who cliff was that he
was on the phone with
i think that's just his fbi friend uh i
think we learned from this show
don't read too much into friends at
other agencies
that they call or text because clearly
now the aerospace engineer drives me
nuts because it's like you spent
multiple scenes building
there have this up that in the damn
mailman i'm holding on to it he did it
again
he had another line he said don't shoot
the messenger and i was like who was the
messenger
i know that you're a physical messenger
but who's a messenger
i'm wondering now if dennis the mailman
is
his uh because you know the post office
is a federal agency maybe that's the job
they got him
oh i don't think he's a scroll but he
was on their board i just wonder if like
we never got a very close-up look of uh
dennis the mailman's uh
his identifying uh piece of paper on the
board
i wonder if jimmy's like hey here's my
missing guy and now he's being warped
into this like weird mailman
guy actually you know what he wasn't now
that i think of it he was a pizza
delivery guy
which also could work you could imagine
that being your job if you're in federal
witness protection as you're a pizza
delivery guy
i i don't think there's gonna be more to
it than that i don't think there is
either
again thanks to privacy for sponsoring
this episode privacy is a tool that
makes it super easy to manage your
financial lives online while keeping all
of your information secure
by generating virtual numbers privacy
masks your bank information so you never
have to worry about giving it out to
those
nerdy wells lurking behind all the
internet corners it's easy to share
cards with friends and family using
privacy's shared cards
parents can set caps on how much the
kids can spend and businesses can send
cards
with spending limits to employees for
company expenses
you can buy the office donuts carl but
no stopping at bass pro
shops for camping gear i like privacy
for recurring payments like for
streaming services that i want some
months but not the month after
so i've set up a privacy account linked
my bank account and created a card
specifically for
my netflix subscription payment so like
if i only want this for a month then i
forget as i always forget i can just set
it for one month to begin with and then
privacy will
ding you if they try to charge the card
twice if charge exceeds the amount you
set for it and then you can just like
let
things you forget about die off it's so
great and you can fill out your credit
card info
in the privacy.com chrome and firefox
extension and you're one click away from
spending smartly and safely just head to
privacy.com
new rockstars and sign up for an account
new customers will automatically get
five dollars to spend on your first
purchase
go to privacy.com new rockstars and sign
up now
uh let's take another question okay so
my question is is what do you want to
see most
from wanda in future events
in multiverse madness and anything else
she is in
yeah so i want a multiverse of madness
to be the event that establishes mutants
uh i hope it's a house of m style event
and i hope that in her pursuit
to try to find her kids she goes into
reality where mutants exist and somehow
that reality gets merged with ours and
then we end
multiverse madness with mutants there
was some speculation report that
marvel might be working on a title
called the mutants that just came from
one of these scoopers who
you know conveniently love to scoop
stuff on hours before a big marvel title
is about to come out
right when it'll blow up the most on
social media so that's why
i don't trust most of these scoopers but
uh i do hope that an x-men
thing comes soon and that is the way
they do it so personally
i want that and then on emotional level
i want wanda not to be an outright
villain but just a figure who teaches us
how to feel
in the mcu i think one division has been
so good at that it's just embracing
empathy
for characters emotional grief and i
want more of that and i want wanda to be
the leader of that in the mcu
i think i agree i think but the only
thing that i personally
am like i want
yeah yeah i want a female villain but i
also want
we can't get wanda not being a
straight-up villain without her saying
no more mutants so it's like i still
want that line of not the no more
mutants but something of the such i want
that line
somewhere in there so it's like she has
to get rid of every something
in order to say that line so i think
that's what equivalates like in
an equation for her to be a villain so
i like i want to see that really badly
that line or some sort of
piece of that line so whether it's her
straight up just like getting rid of
something
and that's sometimes what it's gonna
have to be um but then also
i do want i want the x-men to show up so
much but now i feel like it's less
likely or they're gonna do it and
they're just gonna shove it down our
throats with one movie
not like one movie but like they're
gonna be like out of nowhere it's like
okay here's your movie
and then internals we'll know hopefully
they talk about it but i don't know
it doesn't seem like it seems like
they're still like structured for just
mcu stuff
um and then they're well yeah it's in
the mcu but like they're like just
structured for what they've already been
doing and then kevin feige once he gets
like the actual like
we're gonna green light this thing right
now they're gonna slide it in but we
just don't know it yet
so i think they're just trying not to
even think of the x-men right now
well and i think the biggest um uh nail
in the coffin of this mutants theory and
i could be totally wrong you know i
don't know what sources these scoopers
claim they have but uh
i would be surprised if marvel would
just do a title called
the mutants i think it is you know i
think why they would i think they would
do one at a time
like start with cyclops start with just
wolverine start with
you know professor x
um like do solo time there's so much you
can ring out of the x-men
why just do a movie where it's gonna be
a lot of them together
just start with one character at a time
and then build it up introduce this to
each character before you bring them
together in a team
yeah it's about to be their franchise so
it's like treat it like you do the
avengers give them each their own thing
um but then i also realistically i don't
know why
but i just see them being like i don't
want to take power away
from like falcon or bucky or shuri or
whoever and i'm like but you're in the
same franchise now you guys are in the
same universe
give each other each other's due but for
some reason i still think they're gonna
be like
well don't forget about spider-man and
it's like we're not gonna forget about
spider-man we just need to
give each of these people their own
thing too like i know that we
kind of saw it in the 2000s but it's
like you can redo it make it
better come on please do it also bring
in more x-men that we haven't seen give
them their own storyline
give darwin a new storyline please
just give darwin his movie please first
five seconds
yeah exactly yeah i think if it doesn't
end up happening through the multiverse
i
i honest and people hate it when i bring
up this theory but
honestly the easiest way narratively is
to just suggest that they've been
there the whole time oh yeah i'm gonna
say the scrolls have been at all times
and i think that's what eternals might
be i think eternals is gonna
show us the the origin of mankind and
mutant kind and deviant kind
and eternal kind and maybe even uh
uh no but i think that's i hope we get a
hint towards
uh apocalypse you know like he was the
first mutant
in human history i think right yeah he
was the first one on earth at least
and i want to get some hint since we're
going to h in egypt let's just see a
hieroglyphic with the
with apocalypse there please give us
that give us it to it give it to us
again
i hope but i do think i think you're
right it's like they can't i don't know
they can't go in like
all guns blazing x-men i think they're
gonna just like slowly
like drip it in yeah so it's gonna be
like yeah yeah they've been here
they've just been like we're gonna see
reed richards immediately just like
doing science in like this building that
we've already seen and it's like wait
what
wait he's been here this entire time and
it's like yeah we gotta slowly trickle
it in we can't just
shove it down you gotta take bites you
can't just swallow the full hamburger
no choke exactly chew it
all right let's take another question
what the hell was mr scratchy
why did we not hear anything about the
bloody rabbit after all this time
our theory about the rabbit kind of went
out the window too
oh yeah yes it did there was no rabbit
at the end
you just ate that cicada cicada
bird and never showed up again yeah
yeah uh the rabbit did not show up
one of our loose threads yeah i don't
think it's holes i think it's just i dug
too deep
i think i mean my best answer for you is
that it was um
mcu agatha's version of her cat in the
comics she has her cat ebony and this is
just her animal
counterpart and they made it a rabbit
why
maybe to throw us off the scent a little
bit still demonic
earth demonic yeah craft
it can encompass rabbits as well as
goats and
cats sure they were like it should be a
goat it can't be a goat
it can't be a goat it's gotta be around
yeah it's again
expectation management right like they
bring back that rabbit again and again
and again
i don't blame them for naming it senor
scratchy although do rabbits scratch
i get i don't have never owned a rabbit
dog i held a rabbit scratched the crap
out of me
or accident yeah uh so i don't blame
them for naming it
everyone there's a million different
ways you can look into any character
name
uh but like bringing that rabbit back
making it the close-up when it comes
back from her
from her you know origin story and
episode eight
they put a lot of focus on that rabbit
and literally did nothing with it in the
finale it's like you didn't need to
include all those shots of the rabbit
exactly how i feel about the mailman i
was like
there is way too many which i'm sure not
everyone thinks of
i'm just literally a media studies kid
where i was like you guys spent
way too much time on this man you gave
him way too many lines
way too many close-ups i'm going to
think there's something very important
about it
um and saying you're scratchy i was like
oh dude that rabbit's getting
way too much stage time but
uh we'll talk more we have an our next
episode of inside marvel we're gonna go
really deep into all these like loose
ends these unanswered questions
this plus many many others so we'll
we'll have hopefully some better answers
for you then
i think the easter eggs that you guys
were finding throughout the show like
like each week while it was airing
weren't meant to be found until like
years later
when like mephisto actually makes an
appearance like how we've been doing
with the movies
so like they didn't
you're right you're right i think some
of these things and and you know what
that's why i call them like details if
you watch our videos because missable
detail
number one number two uh some of these
are intentional easter eggs
some of them are just like interesting
cinematic choices like
in episode six when i found that whole
vfx thing of the woman who was
pinning up her decorations in her yard
and i found out how they did like a
split screen with her husband just so
they could change up the sinking of time
just to
put that sense of unease in your head
like things like that are what interests
me when i'm watching stuff when i find
little filmmaking details that the that
show like some kind of creative thought
by the editor by the director by the
writer and so sometimes these
things like the ship of theseus i can't
really call it an easter egg but it's
like an interesting choice you know
um so and these details give
a new layer of meaning it's not always
an easter egg pointed to some
character's arrival or some big theory
that's been confirmed
but it just shows you that this is art
and there's a lot of craft that goes
into it
and it's just interesting to see these
things that like oh
the way they did the lighting they added
a red filter to this like that's cool
for this episode was in other episodes
but you are right in terms of our
theorizing yeah i mean we start to
connect the dots in ways that the
writers did not intend us to connect
yeah
uh that is on us but it's also like you
know it's it's
kind of fun to do that week to week and
just uh speculate
and as long as at the end of it which we
don't do this we don't be like that's it
i'm canceling disney plus subscription
we i'm happy to take whatever ending
they're gonna give us um but recognize
that there is a responsibility
by the director and the writer to
understand how an audience is going to
interpret this and when your core
audience
is are people who love marvel films and
you put in evan peters in this how do
you think they're going to react
hey and i know that that year the game
of thrones
finale came out wants their joke back
but
nah it's nothing like that it's not like
nothing like game of thrones it's
nothing like the end of game of thrones
dude so yeah because
the ending of game of thrones they
completely stopped caring about who
daenerys was as a character who jon snow
who tyrion
like uh i don't have a problem with bran
being king by the end of it
but they rushed all this they did my
brand
so wrong jamie lannister
oh what it was like they forgot who
their characters were
and they had this outline of where their
characters needed to go and then they
completely forgot to characterize which
one division did not fall into that yes
one division did such a good job
understanding who
they always kept wanda's character
journey as a priority and that's why i
think
on that end they stuck the landing they
muddled up some of the fan service stuff
forgivable i think because they kept the
heart of the show true and it was this
relationship between wanda and vision
and understanding wanda's journey to
understand who she is as the scarlet
witch
and by the end of it i think they did
that i think it was success
it looks like we have time for one more
question we're gonna take it here what
do you guys think about ralph's powers
what i mean by that is ralph using
quicksilver's powers
without being quicksilver and there
there was no explanation
do you guys think it was agatha's
necklace i gave him the powers or what
do you guys think
yeah i think that was the uh the
inference there right
like uh he's he has his necklace
and that's how she's giving him all of
his powers
yeah uh which is interesting because it
implies that she can
give uh people she can control her
minions whether it's ralph or anyone
else in the town
the superpowers right she's so why
didn't she do that more
she's smart why didn't she do that with
her why didn't she let science why
didn't she let uh herb the neighbor
become invisible or burst into flames or
shoot lasers out of his fingertips
also she didn't pop she said that when
like dottie turned back she's like what
did you do to her she was like i didn't
do anything i just cut your strings
like that was her magic it was wanda's
magic she can't just like income she
couldn't just like turn this man evil
she was like i wanted to learn about you
i was watching you because
it made no sense how you were doing all
this and i'm tired of waiting so i'm
just gonna
choke your children out right and i
think the idea was uh
the uh making ralph this random actor in
westview new jersey
a speedster uh it was really a
reflection of agatha
trying to convince wanda that this was
her brother
aaron taylor johnson pietro and who
would see he was a speedster so in order
for wanted to be convinced this person
also needed to be a speedster
but it does set up some interesting
implications that the show didn't really
address
like if she could make him shouldn't
give anyone superpowers do you think it
would be useful for agnes to do this
more by the end like she at the end
awoke all the people of of west view to
kind of turn
at wanda and yell at her why didn't she
just give them all necklaces to turn
them all into crazy superheroes so that
she could fight her you know well she's
still wondering
she has to which is a weird kind of
which i guess rule i think consensually
she had to take her
like she had to like because that's what
happened with the other one she shot her
so yeah i think she had to like give it
to her
keep her focus on her to get that
like this is how she absorbs but yeah
she had to absorb
things but like the rules of ralph
is one of the weirdly underwritten parts
of this show
because imagine imagine if if ralph was
not evan peters imagine if it was just
some random dude
uh you know imagine if it was like
freaking zack woods or something like
that
just some other great sitcom actor and
like
it would be goofy and funny in its own
way but then by the end we would still
be confused we'd be like
wait so how is he he's just through this
necklace
like he's being controlled by her he's
just this other dude
like it just feels like they brushed
past it
and i i i even without evan peters it's
still a little confusing to
anyone watching this not just the fans
who have been confused by evan peters
it was truly just for us it was just for
the fans it was like a nod but we
not even we read too into it they
shouldn't have put it in there
not to not to not to like literally put
notes on your screenplay
but we were going to read too much into
it and be like oh this is what's going
to happen
but it was literally just like a yo
isn't this
funny it's a tv show and we're putting
quicksilver
right from sony or from um the other
franchise from the fox the universe yeah
that's clearly
clearly how it was intended and i think
ultimately
and i have some theories on why they did
this and what this tells us about
marvel's plans for mutants in the mcu
well we'll talk about that on wednesdays
inside marvel
but really i think this is just the fact
that one division was never intended to
be the first marvel phase four title oh
yeah which is i think
the fact that we would look at this
after i think our longest gap since
phase one between movies
that fans would devour this as
ravenously as we have
i don't think marvel could possibly
could possibly understand
how that would be interpreted i would
argue they should have expected a bit
more
especially since everyone has been
waiting for years
for to see how feige will reboot the
x-men i think
i think they should have known better
than to just think evan peters would
just be seen as a joke
or just a funny thing that we would
laugh off but hopefully they learn this
lesson i don't think it was disastrous
for the mcu by any means i think i
still love the show and i think it gave
way more to the mcu than it took
far more it definitely isn't game of
thrones
all right we are going to uh close out
with just a couple of comments here from
you guys
i just want to say thank you to you eric
and jessica
both um and then the off-screen
uh people behind the scenes for taking
us on such a great journey this year i
really do appreciate it and i love
every single thing that you guys put out
wrong or not thank you i think that's
that's so sweet of you to say
i know we're not always like reliable
when it comes to the accuracy of our
theories but we really are just trying
to have fun with this
and just try to pitch stuff that you
know jessica and i are writers
like stuff fun stuff we'd like to see
based off of uh the trajectory of things
and
you know ultimately gratitude is is what
we try to
cling to and not this entitlement that
we're owed anything and
it seems like you feel the same way and
we appreciate that personally i think i
love having just to chat with the people
when i get to have the chat with the
people
on twitter um mainly because i was like
now going forward though one division's
over
i falcon winter soldier i'm still gonna
watch it at midnight
and i'm probably gonna tweet about it
with you guys and be like
y'all i need to talk this out like there
was some times where i did like talk to
you guys to talk it out because i was
like
oh yeah i forgot that so it's like you
guys are
very necessary like i need oh yes
well you are necessary to us because i'm
not joking folks
this journey that you've loved it is
just beginning friends we got
winter soldier we got loki we got all
these other marvel facebook titles
we have marvel movies coming back
hopefully
soon it's going to get wild and that's
why i'm saying we got all these new
projects and properties jessica is going
to be part of it we got all new
team members who are going to be joining
the lineup you guys start doing
rogue theories i want to be on all the
ones for eternals
i i want to talk you're getting this
eternal
life we need you we need you there yeah
all right and then one final comment
here thank you both for all your work
you make being in fandom amazing and fun
oh we thank you thank you as well that's
so good we're here for you guys um
okay so we're gonna wrap it up for now i
gotta jump on this breakdown
uh and by the time you're watching this
on youtube it will already be
out there in the world but we want to
thank you guys so much for joining us
it's been such a delight
uh breaking this down we'll be back for
one more inside marvel episode on
wednesday
uh be sure to stick around on stereo
because we got a bunch of great new
shows that are gonna be coming out
nearly every day of the week if we can
help it
uh so uh thank you so much be sure to
follow jessica
lulu underscore clemens on twitter and
follow me at eavos
be sure to check out one of our great
merch options newrockstarsmerch.com
and uh uh follow new rockstars on all
social media subscribe to new rockstars
on youtube hit that notification bell to
get our videos as soon as they come out
uh jessica it's been lovely thank you so
much of course as always
goodbye
[Music]
you